If you think that matcha tastes like grass,
then you just haven't had a good matcha.
Let me show you how to make one.
You're gonna Wanna start by heating up some warm water.
Not hot, warm.
You're gonna use this whisk
and you're gonna soak it in some warm water to soften the bristles.
I got this matcha set and this matcha on Amazon,
and I think it's great for beginners.
I use about a teaspoon of matcha,
and then I sift it through because of how fine the powder is.
And then I add the warm water,
not hot. And you wanna do Z whisking motions until it's a nice frost.
And then my favorite thing has been to add vanilla bean paste
and the stevia.
It tastes so good.
You could also add honey or maple syrup.
And then I use half a cup of almond milk and half a cup of this
half and half.
That's absolutely delicious.
And then you have the perfect homemade matcha. Try it out.